il a mis les formes j'ai appelé
geneviève de fontenay geneviève
geneviève tu m'entends
bon est-ce que tu regarde la télé en ce
moment elle est en direct et on parle de
évidemment il ya nathalie marqué avec
nous pernaut et il ya monsieur hubert
guérin qui travaille avec toi qu'est ce
que tu aurais envie de dire en direct en
tout cas c'est gentil que tu décroches
qu'on entend
[Musique]
alors il ya eu très chaud pas tricher
comme tu l'as laissé entendre geneviève
est ce qu'il ya eu triche ou pas triche
comme tu l'a laissé entendre mais aussi
technique truc un jeu truqué ou pas
truqué cette élection la première
élection avec nature
voilà merci
diffusé
en direct et
avec avec nos écharpes le résultat
entre
miss réunion
oui c'est ce qu'on a vu dis-moi
geneviève pas pardon moi je ne viens
mais tant collaborateurs a parlé de miss
camping est ce que ça te choque en
parlant de me sens on en a encore
bassila d'où
les
castrations
mais alors malheur elles viennent et
geneviève dans l'émission là on a
diffusé les images les enfants s'il vous
plaît c'est difficile déjà au téléphone
s'il vous plaît
vraiment on a diffusé les images en haut
tu laisse entendre sur notre stand
people que c'était bizarre l'élection de
nathalie qu'est ce que tu as envie de
lui dire elle est sur le plateau avec
nous en direct elles étaient très
tristes de cette histoire
nathalie était très triste de ton
histoire
nathalie baye nathalie martin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il faut la sortir rend compte qu'elle
était
et en 2005 18 ans après son élection je
fais un livre avec sylvie tellier ou
jeudi qu'elle a été mis en rayon de
soleil à et ensuite de 2005 à 2010 8 je
prends contact avec elle pour tous pour
souhaiter à bourran que les opérations
de son mari je place que le brillant
comme un coq comme ça c'est assez pour
faire pression il me répond j'ai donné
quand tu es formule et moi j'ai donné
exactement j'ai transmis ce cas russes
ont remporté à sur le celui qui venait
pour être non pour bon pour que vous le
donne et que vous le montrez que vous le
montrions
justement geneviève geneviève tu
m'entends geneviève tu sais que l'on
t'aime beaucoup tous ici on est tous
désolés de cette histoire tu que tu
m'entends on est tous des zones et cette
histoire nathalie est là et triste
franchement il va être combative mais
triste mais qu'est ce que tu aurais
envie de lui dire allez pas triste donc
n'est pas triste bonjour mais attend
vous sentez rien
est à maltraiter non mais vraiment effet
en 2005 malheureusement notre amitié
s'est arrêté là et vous savez pourquoi
malheureusement parce que vous étiez
comme il déjeune merkel moi y'a eu avec
el hadi zablit numéros s'enchaînent pas
oublié geneviève je peux te passe et
nathalie
[Rires]
gavin thévenet
midam attend
geneviève attend les jeunes viennent
pardon de te couper je te passe nathalie
mais parce qu'on vous aime toutes les
deux et ça nous fait de la peine ah ben
si on t'aime non on attend
maintenant non non non non non non non
je suis la malade de février très
contente de vous entendre de nouveau
téléphone ce sera mieux que que vous en
voyez quelqu'un d'autre à votre place
donc vous savez que pour moi vous avez
été une deuxième mère d'ailleurs j'ai
mon livre qui sort aujourd'hui et j'ai
tout un chapitre sur vous je dit que du
bien
malheureusement depuis 2005 c'est vous
qui avez commencé en me disant que je me
faisais culbuter dans les bottes de
paille quand j'étais à l'émission
pour parler de madame de fontenay
c'est vous-même défense et qui m'avait
parlé comme ça généreux oui il ya très
longtemps c'était en 2005 pour la ferme
célébrités tous les journalistes mais
inventer une histoire avec eux ducruet
et que jean pierre pernaut était le roi
du cocu vous m'avez soutenu j'ai eu
pendant trois mois à la presse où on va
on m'a complètement fracassé et comme
j'ai pop je n'avais pas parlé avec vous
et vous étiez pas contente parce que je
parlais pas avec vous pendant trois mois
et vous avez sorti ça la presse
jean-pierre il en est témoin vous avez
pas dire que mon mari jean pierre
pernaut qui est un menteur aussi vous
avez peut-être oublié mais cette phrase
m'a fait super mal et quand vous voulez
mais comment voulez vous attaquer à ce
moment là que moi je ne parle pas mal
j'ai bien sûr j'ai le respect de votre
âge j'ai le respect de tout ce que vous
avez pu me donner mais là franchement en
2005 vous m'avez abattu
ah oui regardez toute ma vie
ensuite
deux
choses avec opportune en est ce qu'on a
travaillé six ensemble parce que j'ai eu
un petit la 6ème dauphine de mission et
à la travaillent ensemble will
j'ai dit que vous avez été vraiment
rayons du soleil oui alors à près de
2500 en
1982 1990 je vais vous envoyer des sms
quand votre mari depuis son opération ça
c'était beaucoup plus tard c'était pas
en 2005 c'était beaucoup plus tard c'est
vrai vous m'avez envoyé un message pour
demander si jean-pierre allait bien et
comme la saf et où ils ne savaient
exploser les journalistes n'arrêtait pas
de ma paie et je vous ai dit oui merci
va bien et vous m'avez juste répondu
c'est tout
vous avez continué là on va peut-être
pas très aisée des données j'ai transmis
nous espérons leur contenu sera à portée
de tous et des réglages
vous avez bien dire abandonner ses pages
et j'ai quelquefois la tête qui
travaillent en français parce que vous
aviez dit mais j'ai tanger transfert
simplement les réponses mais les deux
oui et si on passait par un bisou en
tous les cas car je
joue
non mais non mais c'est normal c'est
vous qui m'avez qui commence à me mal me
parlez donc ça m'a fait mal au coeur
j'ai pas voilà on va pas faire ping ont
ensuite et a eu plein de choses donc
mais tout ça c'est pas grave vous savez
la santé c'est ce qui est le plus
important dans la vie et que l'on puisse
se regarder dans un miroir comme vous
j'espère et voilà il faut il faut
s'aimer dans la vie il faut arrêter de
chercher des embrouilles vous avez grâce
à vous il ya eu miss france qui a existé
ça a été une très très belle aventure il
faut laisser mais non les mains entre
sylvie tellier endemol qu il le fait
très bien il faut arrêter de
lui
bon ça patauge ans a relancé en
mai très fort gratuite donc elle a tout
bon
avec des effectifs en forme geneviève
pardonnez-moi geneviève jeu
je t'embrasse très fort on n'entend plus
là vraiment
[Applaudissements]
je te rappellerai un tunnel je te
rappellerai
mais oui vous allez vous réconcilier
goethe en france ma bonne vieille bisous
et je n'arrive pas la coupe bisous
bisous